foreign
Bully's family have been desperate for
answers that so far no one can give
a private search team has been helping
the police this week and today took the
missing woman's partner to the riverbank
where her phone was found to explain
that after three days of intensive
searching of this part of the river they
have found nothing and are now calling
off their search
I said that if Nicholas here I'll find
her if Nicola was in that River I would
have found her I can guarantee you that
she wouldn't have we would we would have
found her and she's not there in that
section of the river up there my
personal View getting carried out to the
sea I think it's a long way to go in a
tidal River at Watson you know a tide
that goes out a tide that comes in I
would have thought
that she would have surfaced by now and
been found by dog walkers that's my
honest opinion I'm totally baffled by
this one to be honest
hopes this Specialist Team could provide
some clue as to what happened on the day
she disappeared whilst walking her dog
after dropping her daughters off to
school
Specialists dive teams from Lancashire
police have continued their work today
searching kilometers of the river wire
we understand that this will continue
looking for any shred of evidence any
indication any fact that might try and
answer that question what happened to
Nicola bully on Friday the 27th of
January
police teams are searching the river
down to the Sea they still believe no
one else was involved in Nicola Bully's
disappearance Catherine avatarsi Sky
News Lancashire